Chris Harrison hosted The Bachelor his
Michigan State versus Virginia in the
championship game with Virginia winning
at all Chris good to talk to you who
came up with this strategy of your
bracket challenge it was between me and
my 15 year old daughter I mean no idea
is this having been a sportscaster for a
long time and then you know following
the tournament it's just a matter of
knocking out the number one seed you
gotta take some shots and you talk about
that you were a sportscaster but at what
point did you say this isn't what I want
to do or maybe I'm not
maybe somebody decided that for you you
know it is more decided I guess for me
are laid out in front of me because my
goal was never to switch my goal is
actually to continue doing sports
casting but when I moved to LA and I was
doing horse racing and still sports
casting for the most part that's when
The Bachelor came up and all of a sudden
that opportunity just made itself
available and and I and I took a shot
and it turned into what it is but there
was really no discernable shift or
decision to go you know what I'm gonna
get out of this it just kind of happened
who are you up against for the host of
that role of Bachelor host I will tell
you one there it came down to the Final
Four and I can tell you there was there
was one because I've never talked about
this but I know dr. Drew was actually up
for it at the time okay okay and you
have to think again you're like that
seems odd but this is this is 20 years
ago yeah so you can't tell me the other
two I only know one of the other ones
and his name I will protect because he's
still out and about and the other one I
don't know I don't know who the fourth
guy was why do you think they chose you
honestly and this isn't great for me but
they wanted a no-name guy really wanted
and they actually told me that they
really just wanted a you know they
didn't want to love me moving and they
wanted just kind of a no name the guy
next door is how they presented it to me
I was mayor
read I had kids that was important as
well because they didn't want the creepy
guy hitting on the girls they wanted
just an everyday good guy that could
kind of beat a confidant and the friend
for these guys and these women who came
through here would winning the bracket
challenge be the greatest moment of your
life yeah I think I mean yeah I've had
kids that's not a huge deal anybody can
have his my big question though because
I'm only in like 12th or 13th place
right now could you guys not get a hold
of charissa Thompson or Drew Brees this
morning fritzy know what you know what
total transparency we did reach out to
Drew Brees even though he I don't think
he can win it but we thought you know
might him yes fritzy breeze is out of
the country yes with his family five
others were called ahead of Chris
Harrison I just went right to voicemail
but you can you have a chance to win
Chris there's only four of us that I
have a chance to win so that's that's
part of the reason why we're there who
do you who do you have in the finals
Michigan State winning but I had oh yeah
I had Mario our intern picked my
brackets I just I just went through it
and said okay when can I not Duke out
when can I not North Carolina House
because everybody's going to choose them
and then take your shot okay this is
what I'm thinking if you win at all I'm
gonna let you host this show whenever
you want it okay that's that's that's
twice you owe me then yeah yes so you
got time basically
I'm basically building up a week yes you
wanted there was the passion there was
the passion bucket reference and that
earned me the right to host a show and
now now if you don't win I think the
dance get to be extras on a bachelor or
bachelorette episode that can be done
like you could have the couple going to
a bar or a restaurant I could have the
dance at another table there or they
could be the waiters oh and by the way
can I just put out a public service
announcement there is a there's a DP fan
out there and I say fan it might be more
than that every time I say anything on
Twitter on Instagram all I get is
passion
I saw so whoever that is that I get it
I love the D show just as much as you do
but take it easy okay this is what it
sounded like when Chris Harrison star
The Bachelor dropped a passion bucket on
an episode this has happened once before
a hundred percent success rate for this
happening on the job it's good to see
that your passion bucket is still full
and I love now to news they looked when
you said your passion bucket the great
thing they just have to smile and go
along with it I'm driving this bus but I
will say kudos to me that was smooth yes
it was yes a round of applause for Chris
Harrison of The Bachelor what's
happening with Colton under where's he
still running around he's still run
around huge cast you're doing good
they're actually very much in love and
it's actually looking looking really
good right now and right now we're
actually in the middle of shooting
Hannah season of The Bachelor
it's they're like you got a drama and
you and we add - how many - let me okay
let me go back here how much drama level
1 to 10 are we so far with with her we
have some level 5 drama we probably had
four or five man tear moments already
that's a lot of man's here who's the
biggest baby who's ever been on The
Bachelor well I mean aside from Cole's I
mean the big man and Cryer we ever had
and then the reason it's called pulling
a mesnick's was Jason mesnick's if you
remember who's the one who made the
original switch and he was feeding over
the balcony on the final episode in New
Zealand and we now call it you are
eating over a balcony so it's the crying
zero to full Mesnick that is awesome
hey more importantly than the
bachelor/bachelorette good luck on
Saturday with your your March Madness
well this is huge and on a more selfish
note not
wouldn't love to win your bracket but
I'm also in another bracket that's going
to make me a lot more than just hosting
your show one time and cuz I put both
eyes I only did one bracket and I put
them both into all my my little
tournaments so this could be good
how much can you win I don't know the
total but it would be several thousand
dollars it could be good yeah but I have
a certificate that I I'm gonna give out
to the winner like it do I get a plaque
it's not framed it's a piece of paper
you're going to frame it but it's a
certificate of appreciation from winning
the bracket does it come with like it
did it come with a discount code to get
it framed readjust no I'm 100%
responsible for the frame yeah that's on
you that's on you Wow yeah okay well
hopefully I win the other bracket
because then I can pay to get it framed
good luck this weekend Chris thank you
all right go Virginia that's Chris
Harrison host of The Bachelor as
Michigan State Virginia with Virginia
winning at home for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]